a few of you might know that I'm a big
fan of the television series Doctor Who
and recently a friend of mine called
nerimon you might have heard of him as
invented his own music genre called Time
Lord rock which is basically music about
the TV series Doctor Who together me and
nerimon and two other people called
little ranch in Karen parachute have
formed our own Time Lord rock band
called chameleon circuit and I've
written a song the song is called blink
based on episode 190 of Doctor Who at
the moment it's just me playing it on my
own but I'm sure sooner or later the
band will get together and we will do a
communal recording but for now please
enjoy my version of the link
Sally Sparrow I wrote you a letter to
make you feel better about the back down
and gone I may be stuck in the past but
my future is fast don't go looking for
me girl you've got to go on don't think
he's talking to you he's just on the TV
well it has the Easter Egg you'll see
the reality a world of time is facing
side of funny blue box the Hindus are
approaching and the front door is locked
so don't blink I said don't blink just
put directly at them and they'll stay
where they are
you're crying anyway they can't be no
harm my eyes are watering I'm right on
the brink I'm sure nothing would happen
here if I were to the doctor isn't here
this time this won't be your place he's
stuck at ninety sixty nine on your DVDs
just listen very carefully to what he's
got to say do not turn your back on them
don't look away coz if they get inside
the TARDIS then the Sun will go out just
go down to the cellar and show them once
your about table faster than you
don't let the light go out and don't be
naive lose don't like I said don't blink
just look directly at a man they'll stay
where they are I think they're crying
anyway they can't be no harm my eyes are
watering I'm right on the break I'm sure
nothing would happen if I were to the
futures coming quickly so please don't
be scared
the answers we'll find you just make
sure you're prepared when you see the
doctor then you'll work out the link but
even though it's ended please be sure
not to blink
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo beauty